[Music]
on this saturday night a thousand days
of detention
the calls on the justice minister to
free the two michaels i sincerely hope
that we are at the end and the
propaganda in china calling for the
release of huawei's cfo breaking news
from the campaign trail the liberal
candidate accused of misconduct drops
out aid groups try to negotiate help for
the women of afghanistan the elimination
of women means the elimination of human
beings as fears for their safety grow
and the love for the canadian teen
sensation at the u.s open
[Music]
global national with robin gill
good evening and thank you for joining
us this weekend marks one thousand days
since canadians michael kovrick and
michael spavor were imprisoned in china
in what the prime minister calls trumped
up national security charges their
supporters are organizing a solidarity
march walking seven thousand steps it's
something kavrik's wife says he does
every day in his prison cell their
detention is largely seen as retaliation
for the arrest of huawei executive mong
wong zhou in vancouver
as jeff semple reports many china
watchers believe a resolution in the
hmong case is the only way to bring the
canadians home
it's a difficult milestone for the past
1 000 days veena najibullah has waited
for the phone to ring with news that her
husband michael kofrig is free that is
what i focus on every day when i
start the day and wonder what what i can
do today to bring that closer to
reality i mean that is the mission the
goal is to get him on a plane to toronto
that goal has just inspired a song
called the plane to toronto
produced by kovrig's old punk rock band
he was their singer back in the 90s to
raise awareness about the detention of
kovrig and michael spavor accused of
espionage chinese state media now claims
spavor took photos and videos of chinese
military equipment which he then sent to
kovrik the article cites a source close
to the matter
the canadian government calls those
allegations baseless and claims their
detention is retribution for the arrest
of chinese telecom executive mangwon joe
at the request of the united states
[Music]
beijing marked a thousand days of mung's
detention with propaganda and a petition
of nearly 15 million signatures calling
for her release i think that this is
very much
for a domestic audience as much as it is
for a foreign audience but they are
telling people at home and as well in
the diaspora community
that we're going to stand up for your
rights mong's extradition hearing
wrapped up in august with a ruling
expected later this year the trudeau
liberals have long rebuffed calls for a
prisoner swap mung for the michaels but
if ordered extradited the next canadian
government can and should intervene says
this former head of canada's consular
affairs the lives of two canadians is i
think of sufficient importance for the
minister of justice to have acted long
ago on this case i sincerely hope that
we are at the end uh sort of in the
final inning of this geopolitical drama
and that michael will finally be able to
come home she says every day kovrig
walks seven thousand steps around his
prison cell on sunday hundreds will walk
seven thousand steps through ottawa
marching for the michaels to come home
jeff temple global news toronto
jeff continues his coverage of this case
on his podcast china rising it explores
the political tension between china and
canada
breaking news from the campaign trail
raj ceni who has been accused of
inappropriate behavior has dropped out
of the race he was running for the
liberals in the ontario riding of
kitchener center our auto bureau chief
mercedes stephenson joins us at mercedes
this isn't what the liberals need right
now
no this is a critical riding in an area
that they need to hold on to and the
news actually is coming too late for
them to be able to replace this
candidate with someone else they would
have had to have done that by last
monday so they now don't have a
candidate in the riding in a critical
area at a critical time in the last two
weeks of the election now this all comes
after allegations of unwanted sexual
advances
and inappropriate behavior by raj saney
he has categorically denied those
allegations he says they are
unequivocally false and up until today
liberal leader justin trudeau has stood
by him we haven't heard from mr trudeau
since these developments but i just want
to play a clip from our viewers on the
tone the liberal party took on this
yesterday listen to this
that i have a lead as a leader
from the very beginning
of my time as leader has always taken
very seriously and acted on
and we have
strong
rigorous independent processes in place
to ensure
that anyone who comes forward gets
listened to
gets
worked with
this was increasingly becoming a problem
for the liberals as the narrative built
about multiple allegations against mr
ceni they also went high up into the
liberal party with allegations that
trudeau's chief of staff katie telford
was aware of concerns about saney's
behavior there was a review but the
complainant wasn't interviewed as a part
of that review into sani's office which
he says found no concerns about
harassment although we've not been able
to review that report now it's not clear
whether ceni has jumped or was pushed by
the liberal party and there's also a
question of whether his name will still
be on the ballot or if elections canada
can change that before election day
mercedes stephenson in ottawa thanks
mercedes and tomorrow on the west block
mercedes will be interviewing ndp leader
jagmeet singh you can watch that right
here on global today the leaders of the
ndp and conservative party were on
opposite ends of the country aaron
o'toole was in bc where he was pressed
about whether his party would maintain a
ban on assault weapons here's michael
couture
o'toole says he wants to take canada
back he also says he'll repeal the
liberal ban on assault weapons new
attack ads from the liberals are hoping
to hammer home the message that
conservative leader erin o'toole can't
be trusted commercials call out some
campaign promises and were accompanied
by former ministers on the offensive mr
o'toole refusal to come clean on this on
his plan is disrespectful
to the victims
and the survivors of gun violence during
thursday's french language leaders
debate o'toole said he would not repeal
the liberal ban on assault rifles
brought in last year but his platform
says he would the beretta cx4 storm was
used in the dawson college shooting
o'toole was asked 10 separate times on
saturday to clarify his position on
exactly which weapons would remain
banned and each time he said the same
thing i will say to those those
canadians that we will maintain a ban on
assault weapons and as i've said we will
also have
and it's in our policy
a transparent and public review of our
classification system but which ban he
will maintain isn't clear a conservative
spokesperson told the canadian press
that o'toole was referring to the
prohibition of full-fledged assault
weapons decades ago not the liberal ban
in 2020
heidi rathchen is a survivor of the 1989
ecoil polytechnic massacre she says
o'toole is intentionally staying vague
to cater to gun lobbyists
my take is that he he doesn't want to
tell that he doesn't want to reveal two
intentions to the public
although he
reveals his two intentions to the gun
hobby this is the second straight day
the issue of gun control has dogged the
conservative leader on the campaign
trail and it could continue to be a
problem for o'toole until he clarifies
which guns he plans to prohibit
robin michael couture in richmond bc
thanks mike
jack beet singh spent the day on the
east coast he's once again pitching a
national dental care plan and how he
plans to pay for it abigail beeman is
traveling with the ndp leader
jug meat singh started saturday here in
saint john's talking about a longtime
ndp promise free dental care there is no
separating your dental health from your
overall well-being your overall health
the new democratic plan says it will
help families earning less than 90
thousand dollars a year the party says
it will pay for the estimated 1.5
billion dollar annual cost by
introducing a one percent wealth tax on
canadians with a net wealth of 10
million dollars or more as the third
week of the campaign draws to a close
ipso's pollster daryl bricker says the
ndp are the early winners of the race by
offering a credible progressive
alternative picking up support from
liberals and green voters so what we've
seen in the last election campaign uh
judgment sing and the ndp got uh 16 of
the vote now they're getting 23 percent
they're the biggest risers through the
course of this uh uh through the course
of this election campaign compared to
how they performed in the last election
the ndp is making some changes to how it
campaigns due to the federal covet 19
modeling released friday main streeting
in halifax was replaced by an event with
a smaller group there will also be more
virtual events and the party is
introducing regular rapid testing it is
really sobering it's really troubling
things things look like they could get
really bad
and the most important thing we can do
is to get vaccinated regular rapid
testing has been a requirement of
liberal and conservative campaigns since
day one i asked the ndp leader why he's
only introducing them now he says his
party has had strong health protocols
but didn't directly answer abigail
beeman global news st johns
after being gone for two months
alberta's mask mandate is back in effect
tonight face masks are now required in
all indoor public spaces and workplaces
but not in schools restaurants and bars
will have to stop selling booze at 10
p.m alberta has the highest number of
active coveted cases in canada at more
than 13 thousand the province last
updated its tally thursday reporting
more than 1400 new infections its
highest daily uptick since may ontario
added 944 cases today that's the highest
spike since may 30th
despite the fourth wave next week canada
will open its borders to fully
vaccinated travelers meanwhile u.s
officials are warning americans to
reconsider trips to canada or any travel
over the labor day long weekend fears
over the fast spreading delta variant
are keeping some people home but many
people remain unvaccinated and
uncooperative when it comes to safety
measures jennifer johnson explains
with over 7 600 americans killed by
covet 19 last week the centers for
disease control encouraged the
unvaccinated to stay home this holiday
weekend but we still need your help to
stop the spread of germs and viruses the
transportation security administration
reported a steep drop in air travel the
fewest screenings this week since late
may many travelers are fearful of the
delta variant why wouldn't you be it's
serious it's more contagious than the
last version it's
reason to be concerned several travel
industry trackers are reporting a 10
drop in travel this weekend compared to
2019 including the monahan family who
canceled their yearly trip to disney
world we saw what was going on in
florida and how those numbers were
getting high
we had our fingers crossed hoping it was
just a spike but those numbers never
came down
florida louisiana mississippi and
alabama are among the nation's hot spots
for new cobot 19 infections and deaths
with some of the lowest vaccination
rates over 38 percent of eligible
americans remain unvaccinated folks are
seeing their loved ones get sick get
hospitalized and god forbid dying
fears of the delta variant come as
almost every school in america is back
in session next week with hundreds of
school districts still battling over
mass mandates this arizona principal had
her life threatened after telling
students who had contact with a copa 19
infected person to quarantine under
county rules remember tucson is a small
community and you have a target on your
back many republican governors are still
banning mass mandates in schools as new
data from the american academy of
pediatrics shows more than 20 percent of
kova 19 cases are now among children
jennifer johnson global news washington
coming up the rush to help the women of
afghanistan
[Music]
the taliban has taken over afghanistan
but it's still fighting with resistance
forces to gain control of one last
province pangea valley both the taliban
and the national resistance front are
claiming to have the upper hand the
taliban isn't making life easy there it
shut off power phone and internet lines
even when the terror group controlled
afghanistan from 1996 to 2001 it didn't
have control of pangea valley the region
held out for nearly a decade against the
soviet union's occupation
the taliban claims it's changed since
then but afghan women and girls aren't
buying it fearing the group will bring
nothing but a life of oppression and
suffering as crystal gomezing reports
those who couldn't escape the country
are now in hiding dreading what's next
[Music]
they're asking for so little
these afghan women simply want to remain
active members of society out in society
because without the presence of women no
society will prosper the elimination of
women means the elimination of human
beings
that's exactly what's fueling fears
previously under the taliban women were
mostly confined to their homes the group
still defined as a terrorist
organization by the canadian government
held public executions as it strictly
enforced sharia law
when the taliban seized kabul and
effectively the country on august 15th
people who had worked helping western
nations or acted against the taliban
descended on the airport
in the days since the desperation to
escape has not waned it's just that many
people are hiding
this is a hard question to ask it'll
probably be a hard question to answer
what is it like for you sitting in dc
don't ask
seven hundred afghans are now on sanam
narogi and erlini's rescue list they're
doctors lawyers judges
journalists people associated with their
organization which help shape and
promote peace and security policies
you know
i have people calling oh
they're so nice they're so polite
um
and their lives are at risk and they're
asking us to help them the anguish is
shared by so many aid groups and
organizations scrambling to find ways to
get their contacts out of the country or
at least keep them safely hidden away
but it's not easy and government help is
required i want to be able to say
that i did what i could
and i wish other people would just think
that wherever they're sitting what did
you you know here's a moment what did
you do the taliban has vowed to respect
women's rights and forgive those who
have fought against them
the best many can hope for right now
is that the taliban's word has value
crystal gomanson global news london
still ahead fighting hatred in canada
where islamophobia is rising
in 2020 reports of racially motivated
hate crimes surged by 30 percent and
muslim canadians are one of the most
targeted groups global's morgan black
spoke to three generations who say
islamophobia is getting worse
amal mahamud is a young black muslim
canadian she knows that makes her a
target but she feels it also makes her
powerful i am not ashamed of any part of
my identity i own all three of them
her generation has a new voice through
social media they participate in social
movements they challenge hate me wearing
the hijab plays a huge part in my life
it's a part of my identity and
i don't see myself removing it for
anyone just so they could feel more
comfortable but hate is still happening
the national canadian council of muslims
has been tracking reported anti-muslim
incidents over the past decade i feel
like the attacks have always been there
it's just that more people are vocal
about it now at least nine incidents in
the last nine months have been reported
in the edmonton area disturbing physical
and verbal assaults directed mainly at
black muslim women wearing a hijab or
burka
[Music]
last december there was a string of
assaults within just days of one another
in june a new level of horror to
comprehend four members of the afsal
family were killed while taking an
evening walk in london ontario
deliberately run down with a truck a
nine-year-old boy was the only survivor
his parents sister and grandmother
murdered this is my home end of the day
i shouldn't be feeling this way
edmonton's muslim community has deep
roots in the city it's home to canada's
first mosque opening in 1938 harriet
shaban says young muslims today should
not be made to feel like outcasts i've
been out and i've seen
girls wearing hijab i don't know them
and i've seen people yell at them
it makes me very angry schaben remembers
a city that welcomed her in the 1960s
and the pride she took being part of a
community that dedicated itself to
giving back and becoming an essential
part of edmonton's fabric maybe if like
i said if people
understood it better maybe they would
feel differently
six in ten canadians see racism as a
serious problem facing the country
according to ipsos polling done for
global news it's a double-digit increase
from the end of 2019. black indigenous
and people of color are more likely to
say racism is one of the most serious
problems facing the country and a
growing number of canadians believe
racism has increased in their community
over the past five years we can shift
perspectives and
learn lean towards understanding one
another rather than otherizing senate
atek omar spent her own childhood
immersed in community work she says her
sons will feel that same closeness to
the mosque and to edmonton it doesn't
have to be this or that you can be
muslim and canadian and pakistani and
all of those beautiful things in one
generations of muslims have grown up in
canada or come here to better both
themselves and their communities these
three edmontonians are proof that same
sentiment continues today i feel like
the generation of the past would be so
proud of our generation today
just seeing us you know just stand
strong no matter what happens we keep
moving forward forward into a future
they hope can be free of hate morgan
black global news
go canada up next a quebec teen's
stunning win over a world champ
it was an upset for the ages at the u.s
open canadian leila fernandes eliminated
number three seed and two-time defending
champion naomi osaka during this third
round the 18 year old from laval quebec
pulled off a shocker and advances to her
first grand slam ever in her career
fernandez says she wanted to put on a
show and promises to do it again when
she hits the court tomorrow
well done and team canada gets another
record-breaking gold at the tokyo
paralympics runner nate reich sped past
the competition in his paralympic debut
racing to gold in the men's t-38 1500
meter final he also set a new record for
the event finishing at three minutes and
58.92 seconds the 26 year old american
canadian has broken multiple records in
international competition his victory
marks canada's fifth gold of the games
raising team canada's total medal count
to 21.
well done that is global national for
this saturday night i'm robin gill
tonight your canada is this field of
sunflowers at sultan farm and sanctuary
in ottawa we'd love to see your corner
of the country so please keep sending
your photos to viewers at
thank you for watching and i'll see you
back here tomorrow have a great night
[Music]
you